we're told by the palace that the issue
of titles is going to be something that
is going to be sorted out after the
official mourning period and don't
forget the royals have a further seven
full days of mourning after the funeral
on monday so what of the titles for
archie and lilly which has caused i
think it's fair to say a storm of
controversy well by law now that charles
is king
any sons of the sovereign are entitled
to take the prince title the hrh title
and their children are entitled to take
the hrh title it is why prince andrew's
daughters beatrice and eugenie are their
royal highnesses princess beatrice of
york and princess eugenie of york now
eagle-eyed royal watchers will have
noted that on the official royal website
archie and lillibert are not prince and
princess arch and lily but yet
i think the reason that they are master
archie and miss lilly but still is
because a formal decision hasn't been
taken yet as to the announcement of
those titles are there going to be hrh
it's unlikely given that that is what
harry and megan have dropped but i
believe that it's the case that they
will be prince and princess and i think
a lot rides on these titles are we going
to see this eagerly anticipated
autobiography of harry's are there going
to be more interviews essentially
trashing the royal family the matter of
titles created an absolute storm after
the oprah interview because the
suggestion from harry and megan was that
archie hadn't been given a title
possibly because of concerns over the
color of his skin
i mean this was frankly an outrageous
suggestion the reason archie wasn't
given the title of prince
was because he was the great grandson of
the monarch he would only ever earn that
title or be awarded that title as
grandson of the monarch he is now
entitled to it we just have to see
whether it's bestowed upon him i think
one of the key issues for harry and
megan who we know very much want a below
the radar lifestyle for their children
was the security that of course comes
with being an hrh it means that every
time harry and megan come over here with
their children they get taxpayer-funded
royal protection security and one of the
big issues particularly for them has
been their safety as they come over here
and harry has appealed to the british
home office to be able to pay for the
right for that royal security something
that has been turned down and something
which harry plans to challenge through
the courts here in the uk given the fact
that they are two of the most famous
people on the planet and i think it's
fair to say quite divisive people and i
i think absolutely they have a case in
point for
security a lot of people here believe
that because they're not working royals
they're not entitled to taxpayer-funded
security they've made plenty of millions
of their own they should be spending
that on their private security
[Music]